two identical spheres are released from
a device at time equals zero from the
same height h as shown above or t equals
here i should say c r a has no initial
velocity and falls straight down sphere
b is given an initial horizontal
velocity of magnitude v sub 0 and
travels a horizontal distance d before
it reaches the ground the spheres reach
the ground at the same time t sub f
even though sphere b has more distance
to cover before landing air resistance
is negligible
the dots below represent spheres a and b
draw a free body diagram showing and
labeling the forces not components
exerted on each sphere at time t sub f
over 2. so we can see our spheres here
when i guess this little this thing
releases sphere a goes straight down
sphere b
it it will go
well it's vertical in the vertical
direction it'll go down just the same
way it'll be accelerated in just the
same way as sphere a but it has some
horizontal velocity and that makes it
move out and hit the ground d
to
the right
and when it hits the ground that's t sub
f when they're up here this right when
they're released as t equals zero and
then this is at t equals t sub f
and they say a free body diagram at t
sub f over two so this is why while both
of them are in flight
so when while both of them are in flight
the only force acting on each of them is
just going to be the force of gravity
and since the spheres are identical the
force about gravity is going to be
identical they have the same mass so let
me draw
so that right over there is the force of
gravity on sphere a
and that is the force of gravity on
sphere
b
and so we could write
force of gravity
force
of
force of gravity
and if we want we could call well we
could say the magnitude is f sub g if we
want f sub g
or we could label it as
m times the gravitational field so this
is equal to
is equal to m times the gravitational
field and that's it while they're
mid-flight the only force acting on them
we're assuming air resistance is
negligible is the force of gravity is
going to be the same because they have
the same mass they're identical spheres
all right let's tackle the next part of
this
on the axis below sketch and label a
graph of the horizontal components of
the velocity of sphere a and the sphere
b as a function of time
all right i'll do sphere a first this is
pretty straightforward sphere a if you
will remember
let's go up here sphere a
has no horizontal velocity the entire
time we're talking about it only it's
only going to be accelerated in the
vertical direction it's going to be
accelerated downwards so sphere a has no
horizontal velocity so
i will draw a line like this so sphere a
has no horizontal velocity
the entire time
now sphere
sphere
b
sphere b
is going to be a little bit more
interesting slightly more interesting
its velocity they tell us that its
initial velocity is v sub zero its
initial horizontal velocity i should say
has a magnitude of v sub zero and since
air resistance is negligible it's going
to continue going to the right at v sub
zero until it hits the ground
so
so sphere b if this is and i'm just
going to pick one of these as v sub zero
let's say that this right over here is v
sub zero that's the magnitude of its
horizontal velocity well sphere b is
going to be
at that velocity
actually let me just
make it a little bit clearer it's going
to be at that velocity until
until vf
so
if we say this right over here or not vf
until the final time until t
f so this is t equals zero to t f the
entire time while the ball is in the
while that sphere is in the air it's
going to have a the horizontal component
of its velocity is just going to be
constant it's not going to be slowed
down by anything because we're assuming
air resistance is negligible and then
right when it hits the ground it
essentially if you think about the force
that is stopping it it's essentially
friction
but then it
very quickly goes down to a velocity of
a magnitude of velocity of horizontal
magnitude of velocity of zero
all right
all right now let's tackle the last part
of this
now you could label this if you want
this is let me actually let me label it
this is b
c or b
and this is
sphere
that is the sphere a right over there in
sphere b if you want you could show it
would overwrite sphere a so your b would
be zero after that it's not continuing
to move on to the right or at least they
don't tell us anything about about that
finally in a clear coherent paragraph
clear coherent paragraph length response
explain why the spheres reach the ground
at the same time even though they travel
different distances include references
in your answers to parts a and b
all right so let me think about it i'll
try to write a clear coherent paragraph
length response
so i'll say
the entire time
the
or let me say from
from
t
equals 0
to t equals t sub f
the
only
force
acting
on
the spheres
is
the downward force of gravity is
the
downward
force
force of
right a little bit meter of gravity
at t equals zero
they both
have
zero vertical velocity or the the
magnitude of the velocity in the
vertical direction is zero for both of
them let me write it that way
the
magnitude
of
both of their velocities
both
of
their
velocities
in
the
vertical
direction
is
zero
after
t equals zero
they are accelerated
they are accelerated at the same rate
accelerated
at
the
same
they accelerated at the same
rate
so
their vertical component of velocity
their vertical
component
components
of velocity
velocity are always the same
of
velocity are
always
the same
and they have the same vertical distance
to cover
and
they
have the same
the same
vertical distance to cover
critical distance
to
cover so they hit the ground at the same
time
let me make sure that makes sense after
t equals 0 they are accelerated at the
same rate so their vertical components
of velocity are always the same
let me actually let me
let me write this this way since they
have the same
since
actually let me
they
have the same
vertical distance to cover
vertical
distance
to cover
they will hit the ground at the same
time
they
will
hit
the ground
at
the
same time
same
time
they do have different horizontal
velocities but that does not affect
their that does not affect the time
the their velocities or the distance in
the vertical direction
they
have
different
horizontal
velocities
but
that
does not
affect
the time in which they they cover the
same vertical distance effect
the time
in which
they cover
the same
vertical distance
and you could write something to that
effect
and you could also write that yes if you
were to add the components of spheres
b's velocities it would actually have a
larger velocity if you were to add the
components if you're not thinking in
either the horizontal or the vertical
direction and so it does indeed cover
more distance in space over the same
amount of time but if you think about it
just in the vertical direction it's
covering the same distance in the same
time at any given point in time in the
vertical direction it actually has the
same velocity it's being accelerated in
the same way and it starts off at veloci
of magnitude of velocity of zero